voilà ma chérie je me tourne vers vous
soyez berlin vient tout juste de
confirmer cette livraison d'armes
lourdes des fameux char à l'ukraine on
voit bien qu'on est en train de franchir
une nouvelle étape très très clairement
sergueï lavrov a lui mis en garde hier
soir face aux hauts risques de troisième
guerre mondiale toujours bien réelle
selon lui il ya des choses que cela
dégénère réellement un mail aujourd'hui
oui parce que c'est en train de devenir
grave dans le sens où il ya deux choses
qui rentrent en ligne de compte il ya à
la fois ce qui se fait sur le terrain
l'armement ça c'est toujours une
question fondamentale parce que c'est la
question de la cobp elie gérance qui va
avec et puis l'autre chose qui est menée
frontalement c'est une question de le
faire savoir on est aussi dans la guerre
de la communication et le problème c'est
que lorsque l'on est dans la guerre de
la communication
il y en a toujours un qui risque de
perdre la face et donc à partir du
moment donné où vous envoyer sèchement à
vladimir poutine que vous envoyer ce
nombre là là c'est différent que si vous
l'aviez fait discrètement que les armes
soient opérationnels sur le terrain
terrain mais qu'il n'y ait pas un
déclaratif aussi important sur les
arbres qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que lââm rammstein il y à la
décision d'armer beaucoup plus largement
les ukrainiens dans un cadre plus
important totalement en accord avec la
guerre qui sont en train de mener avec
le dombass les américains leur ont livré
des obusiers ils sont en train de le
faire ont ils n'ont pas encore reçu il
ya une partie qui est en train de partir
72 au billet en avait déjà reçu 9 en
estonie alors ça c'est parfaitement
adapté à des tirs d'artillerie quand
vous êtes dans les plaines du dombass
mieux effectivement que les missiles qui
avait été donné dans un premier temps
les allemands par le des chars qui pour
eux en plus c'est très emblématique
parce que le char pour l'armée allemande
c'est le nec le plus ultra ç'a toujours
été l afld en très légère pour les
français qui a toujours été défendues
mais les allemands eux ils croient dans
le chardon qu'ils mettent du chars
opérationnels et qui va servir sur les
ukrainiens on a évidemment des drones
qui sont des drones kamikaze en plus qui
peuvent se coller contre les cibles et
ensuite vous avez tous le renseignement
bien évidemment qui est mis à
disposition des ukrainiens tout cela est
su dit puisqu'on est sur la base de
ramstein puisqu'on a vu hier
anthony blinken allez voir et nice qui
est en parler donc forcément vous piquez
ainsi légaux de vladimir poutine est
dans une guerre c'est aussi comme ça
vous avez des dérapages à un moment
donné lavrov répondons ce que vous avez
dit on risque d'être sur une escalade
voilà cela n'a pas manqué la réaction
russe ne s'est pas fait attendre
parallèlement il ya ces informations en
provenance de moldavie la mode la vie
qui a convoqué un décidé de convoquer ce
matin une réunion du conseil de sécurité
nationale après plusieurs explosions
survenues en transnistrie région
séparatiste frontalière avec avec
l'ukraine et aussi ce risque de
contagion qui est aujourd'hui bien réel
oui c'est ça en fait la réponse dont on
a peur par rapport à vladimir poutine
c'est qu'il y a une chose à le combattre
dans le cadre du cren dans son invasion
aujourd'hui et le fait qu'il se soit
déplié sur le dombass pour avoir
j'allais dire une structure de guerre
qu'il maîtrise et qui lui permet
éventuellement d'étendre ses territoires
et aussi le fait à modeler de savoir où
est-ce qu'il va s'arrêter on ne connaît
pas le but de guerre de vladimir poutine
donc on ne sait pas si une fois qu'il
aura son morceau de donbass il
s'arrêtera là en se disant que ça lui
donne la mer d'azov et la crimée ou si
il est de santé d'aller regarder un peu
plus loin du côté de la mer noire est
donc de passer du côté d'odessa et sinon
c'est parce qu'effectivement on fait la
jonction avec la transnistrie et donc
c'est pour ça que je vous ai explication
parce que les les explosions que l'on
entend la dent dans la capitale sont
effectivement inquiétante dans la mesure
où on ne sait pas si ce sont des
soulèvements de population si c'est
arrivé comme cela si c'est une demande
faite par les russes tout cela
effectivement et le risque de réponse
russe à ce qui est en train de se passer
ce dont je vous parlais c'est
qu'effectivement armes et les ukrainiens
ça leur donne une capacité de combat
plus importante mais ça veut dire
effectivement une guerre plus importante
et face aux 4 milliards de dollars que
sortent les américains pour armer
vladimir poutine peut se dire qu'il n'a
rien à perdre à l'état paie / dpi pour
l'instant qui ne sont pas sauvés par le
fait qu'il bénéficie de la de l'otan
mais la moldavie n'en bénéficient pas et
peut-être que ce sera une étape en ça ce
serait effectivement la rentrer
complètement dans une autre guerre